what is it with creepy relatives they're
always showing up at the wrong time and
they want to kill you and they want to
skin you and use your skin to hang
wallpaper I guess I just have a weird
family stoker comes to us from the
director of Oldboy a fantastic movie
truly great movie and one of the best
foreign films I think ever made and this
movie stars Maya y Suk Cao dang it I can
never get her name right as I check it
on my phone Mia Wasikowska Mia
vysokovsky Mia Wasikowska her the girl
from Jane Eyre in Alice in Wonderland
she's a good actress go ahead make
comments about how I should spell it and
pronounce it I'll forget the next time I
have to do it I always do her name
confuses me it also stars Nicole Kidman
and Matthew Goode this movie tells the
tale of India Stoker now her father
played by Dermot Mulroney recently
passed away in a car accident
now her uncle is played by Matthew Goode
and he's coming over to kind of comfort
them in their time of need in his own
little special way is psychopath way he
starts to hit on Nicole Kidman despite
the fact that that's his dead brother's
wife and he kind of starts to hit on
India as well and leads her down a very
dark path in which she descends into
this something she descends into some
kind of realm of this is an interesting
movie let me just put it that way Stoker
is a movie that I was looking forward to
see because of the director this guy man
he knows how to shoot a movie and this
movie looks extremely visually
impressive there's a lot of shots from
the movie where I just kind of tilted my
head or I looked and I was just like wow
that's that's really impressive
cinematography and this movie is filled
with it and the plot of this movie is
definitely very cliched and I know that
you kind of want to think well it's
artfully told but the fact of the matter
is we have seen this story many times
where a stepfather will come in or an
uncle will come in or even an aunt or a
stepmother will come in and suddenly
there is a domestic dispute of insane
degree because they're a murderer or
he's a psychopath or something I'm
thinking domestic disturbance with Vince
Vaughn and John Travolta I'm thinking
The Stepfather movie there's a lot of
movies that definitely have a very
similar plot to this there are aspects
of this plot that definitely taken in
different directions with the character
of India where she kind of starts to
take on similar traits that's not as
common and
gotta be honest with you guys as the
viewers that I was very excited for this
movie but it really did let me down this
movie isn't even close to being as good
as the Korean films this director has
made in the past it could be because he
maybe had more studio pressure making an
American movie or something along those
lines I don't know but there is
definitely something here that's slipped
and I'll tell you my reasonings behind
it's very difficult to latch on this
movie because the characters are all
extremely unlikable but the thing that
really kept taking me out of the movie
was the fact that all the actors acted
like they were in a movie after the
movie a friend of mine said that kind of
reminded me of a stage play like
everyone was really huge and bombastic
and really big and just I'm in a movie
right now and I'm going to stand like as
rigid as possible and say all of my
lines like test their camera because I'm
in a movie right now
and I'm an important actor it just
didn't feel real the director made a lot
of weird choices that I didn't really
understand with the way he made the
movie there were certain things about
the way the film was constructive that
really made me confused multiple times
throughout the movie it really felt like
he was trying to take an extremely
simple plot and take it to another art
form which is extremely commendable but
it just didn't work for me also the way
the film eventually ended which I will
not spoil I can kind of see the way it
was going you know you see certain hints
at some of the things that are going to
happen but after you know where the film
eventually goes you start to think back
on the film and things start to not make
sense anymore now I've read a lot about
this movie and some people have
theorized that a lot of the movie
perhaps certain parts of it could be
imagined or maybe that wasn't entirely
real is this in her mind is that in that
character's mind and I think the reason
that I had a hard time latching onto it
is because the movie felt so simple to
me you have the evil uncle who's coming
in and he has an agenda and he's going
to mess up the family but then there's
this whole side of this movie that's
trying to be so analytical and look at
me and look at this and look at that
that I felt like those two things really
clashed I'm gonna give Stoker a c-minus
now I know that a lot of people are
excited for this movie and I truly hope
you enjoy it and I hope that you
appreciate it but I'm telling you if you
are a huge fan of Oldboy a film that I
really appreciate if you go into this
movie don't
to be even near that level I mean it's
just not going to happen but I also want
to let you know that I didn't go into
this movie expecting that I just went
into the movie knowing what the director
is capable of doing and for that reason
I was let down by this movie thanks a
lot for watching guys and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]